Thanks
all right so hello everyone thanks for
making it in the morning and hello to
people on the web so so this talk is
about augmenting streaming algorithms
using machine learning Oracle's to
improve their performance this is joint
work with that Janu Dina and Ali Ali is
here in the audience so I guess the
first thing is I should explain the
title I mean the streaming I'll do is
for frequency estimation is something
that you know most of you have you know
so that we start from explaining what
learning augmented means all right so
the starting point of this talk are the
standard classical algorithms right so
this all the algorithms that have we all
work on and now and laughs right there
are girls that we teach in the
alcoholics courses and for the
prospective this talk the distinguishing
feature is that they have worst-case
guarantees right so we have the Westies
guarantees you know correctness and the
algorithms to be correct they if the
algaas approximately to have guarantees
on their accuracy right you know
potentially running time and so on so
they have lots and lots of a benefits
but they tend to have one drawback right
which is because they are designed for
the worst case they typically don't
adapt well to particular classes of
inputs right now that there has been a
fair amount of work on fixing it right
but you know typically you know we can
improve the algorithm oh if you can
model the equal distribution as well
right
so but you know the guys speaking they
don't adapt very well to just arbitrary
distributions which are given to you all
right so there have been various
attempts to to fix it and in this
article focus on one of them which is
machine learning
approaches okay so what's the machine
learning based approach well you know
the algorithm classical algorithm you
some function right so what we find
input there's all different outputs
right now you can take out those inputs
and outputs right and are trying a
machine learning classify it and it
simulates you know the solution to the
problem right so this approaches have
been a very popular especially over the
last few years and dry speaking you get
a better performance all right so you
know you can get a much stronger
performance by doing it because you know
that's what machine learning does right
machine learning atoms very well through
particular inputs but unfortunately
typically you don't have a very good
control over what the sound of it does
right so you know you don't you often
don't get our whiskey's guarantees right
under it you know can just output some
you know very strange things right so
you know you get a very nice algorithm
quite get in control over what this
algorithm does okay so you know this is
something you know potentially to worry
about
so the letting augmented Alcott's
approach you know tries to get the best
of both worlds which is you know to
retain the adaptivity of the learning
algorithms right but at the same time
getting some control over you know what
this thing does right so so if I if if
it lands well right if I'd it behaves
you know the dots would supposed to do
right and is great you adapt to the
input but you know if it stands getting
crazy you have some westby's guarantees
to fall back on okay so this is
basically what I mean by letting
augmented anger is for the perspective
of this dog all right now we're by far
not the first people to to work on this
topic and so here is our you know some
of the related word that I'm aware of
I try to be thought of but I probably
missed some things right so so
definitely after the talk please now let
me know now this is a laundry list so
just to understand it I mean
I try to put it there to classified it
into three classes okay the first
classes I uses the approach that you
know one can call magic Oracle's right
so in this approach
he was machine learning rights to train
certain Oracle's which are whenever you
want to give you some useful hints about
being right so this is a particularly
useful for our online algorithms right
because online algorithm know the future
right but but you might be able to
predict it right and in a recent work by
liquid versus bits key and a few other
people you know there are various
approaches over how to use those a trade
magic Oracle's rights to improve the
performance of online algorithms are
still retaining some performance
guarantees right the similar approach
has been also used in the recent paper
by T Glasgow at all where if they use
machine learning to implement data
structures right but then they fall back
on standardized structures to fix the
problem of false negatives right so this
is a one type of one approach to use
machine learning to improve classic
there are goals another approach is
something that I called land gadget by
the way these are not very good names if
you guys have any butter knives I was
very much appreciated it's not great you
know but that's the best video to come
up with all right so what's a learn
gadget approach so here the idea is that
the algorithm by definition uses certain
structure like a matrix or something
like that and that the structure is
learned based on the input distribution
right so one example of this forms are
you know line of research called
learning to house
well the idea is that you take the data
set and then you sketch it to preserve
distances right now of course we know
that this can be done using you know
values are randomized techniques right
but these are papers you know starting
from the work of a cyclic open Hilton
essentially take the whole data set and
sketch it a
I thought they typically get a somewhat
better performance because they tailor
to the given input and that more
recently a similar approach has been
applied in compressive sensing so I'm
not getting to what compressive sensing
guys but you know there is a matrix
right that you perform the measurements
and therefore the measurements you
recover your vector right so you know
this works a train either the matrix the
measurement matrix or the recovery
algorithm in order to basically a done
better to the right if you want to know
more about it ask Eric Eric so he he's
one of the authors of the last class is
a Sam hat I called the neural algorithms
and these are basically you know neural
networks all the way ok so just take
your algorithm you implement it like
almost physically writing in a neural
network as a hard work and then you're
trying the hell out of it right so so
this is an end-to-end approach all right
speaker you don't have any guarantees
whatsoever right but often you get a
pretty interesting results and there has
been a recent papers by diet all who
used it for TSP our grocery sticks and
also vertex cover and also Mao Alexander
and all who use it for scheduling
algorithms right so do i speaking you
know like this our approaches provide
the spectrum in the sense that you know
this class of our girls give you some
handle on the worst-case performance
right because this algorithm make some
decisions but in the worst case they
fall back on standard data structures
which means the top things cannot get
too crazy right and I've had this
approaches to the best of my knowledge
you know there's no guarantees right
buyers beware right you know Algirdas
typically work well but you know they
can get arbitrary choice right so our
work falls into this class right we are
also using a form of a magic Oracle's
for a streaming algorithms and uh you
know since we fall into this class you
know we
still retain certain worst-case
performance and also we are able to
analyze this algorithm
so any questions so far
by the way feel free to ask me any
questions yes I mean I guess you could
call them hyper parameters but yeah it's
it's a semantic issue like I understand
this hyper parameters are just like some
some knobs that you can tune right
correct right right yeah I mean here the
gadgets I mean you know like the it's a
fuzzy boundary right but here by gadgets
I mean something which is more inherent
to the algorithm
all right first time for compressive
sensing sensing math leaks is the
inherent part of the algorithm
it's not like a knob right but that is
actually you know one of two main
components of the our code right but
yeah I mean this this specification and
you know with this fastly right you know
it's not like a exact science but that
said you know at least from my
perspective I fried the specification is
helpful right because you know like well
where we teach algorithms right you know
we say okay this is the banner conquer
this is danaiah programming right I mean
the light between the two is often fuzzy
right but it helps to have the semantic
specification right because it helps you
know thinking about various forms of
design just think about the machine
learning as a tool to improve save any
time and space in a way a boss right
because it's our focus on streaming
cargo rates and then there is a
trade-off in space in accuracy right
yeah so so depending on the situation
you try to improve one or the other so
for example here you prove accuracy
accuracy I guess here there is a really
a space sorry the trade-off between
accuracy and measurements to say here we
are here it's the it's time
actually accuracy yeah yeah often
there's a trade offs right yes in the
last category do you use the is there
like a training step before where they
get to see solutions to other TSP
problems or yes yes yes yes so so let's
see so I think that
actually these are kotas here right so
this is the last class I use
reinforcement learning which means it's
like an ongoing process right
you-you-you know computer sector
solutions you get the rewards or not
right and and based on that you you
adjust your policies you know this
algorithm it's a very three sync
instructions but you know there's black
magic good any other questions all right
so in this talk I'll focus on one
particular problem which is frequency
estimation so I guess now most of you
know what it is but I'm just going to
recap it for completeness so this is a
streaming problem right so we are given
a data stream a stream of entries right
for example this one essentially we will
view the stream as a frequency vector
right so for each item right the
frequency vector has a count right you
know for appears if I go to the right
five times right so so we have so if we
cut in that space we just store the the
hole count the cool vector but you know
we don't this is to McHale great right
so what we want is I want to compress it
but still we should be able to simulate
access to this frequency vector with
some approximation right approximation
is due to compression all right so the
goal is to read the stream and then you
know whenever you are asked ok what's
the frequency of I you output some
estimate right which might or might not
be the same as the truth frequency
so this is a frequency estimation
problem it's has lots of applications
I'm not gonna get into details but our
network measurements of them it's using
machine learning and the P security and
so on right and there are many
algorithms
you know both for this problem and the
related problems like heavy hitters
right when you just care about finding
the elements which have high frequency
right there are many variants in the
stock our focus on a hashing based
algorithm referred to as count X okay
were accidents for means catch median
and so on right so those you know can't
mean can sketch convenient right there
are some of the classical algorithm this
problem which are very mostly in how do
you hash and when I was too harsh what's
your estimate right or the high level
all of those Algirdas store a bunch of a
hash table where each hash table in each
bin has a count when you have the new
element you hash it and you increment
the corresponding bin and then if you
want to estimate the frequency you also
charge the element and then take all
these numbers and perform some
estimation right so for count me and you
just take the minimum for count medium
you take the median for come sketch you
do you do a median of means right so you
know they differ but you know there are
roughly the same on a high level and
there are both advantages of a disorder
is one of the chief ones and the handle
deletions right because you know you can
increment but you can also do cleaners
right and also some algorithmic count
mean they never underestimate all right
they can overestimate but they don't
underestimate which is useful in some
situations so this is the class of our
Algirdas data and will focus on and will
try to improve their performance by
using machine learning so before i
described the algorithm let's just do a
thought experiment which is essentially
the following so if we are to hope that
machine learning is to improve the
performance of the sound
is that it means that typical data set
needs to have some structure that can be
exploded right I mean if you just have a
completely random data set without any
structure then you know there's nothing
to let right so you know the question is
you know do typical data sets have some
structure that potential can be
exploited and you know at least in
principle it seems that the answer is
yes right so for example forward data
right if you have the world it's now
that the length of the world is related
to the frequency all right you know
typically frequent words are short and
long words not come up right because
it's not a you know it's a statistical
behavior or it's not exact right but ah
you know there's certain information in
the ID of the element right that's not
as you get the element as opposed to the
hash you can actually get some
information from that similarly for
network data you know some IP addresses
are more popular than others and you
know this is a pattern that can you know
hold for a longer amount of time and if
it not individual IP addresses then you
know IP domains all right you know some
IP domains might be very busy right
because some structure and you know if
you could learn the structure then there
is a hope that that we could use it to
improve the archives
right and in particular like when you
say like some say I got this is popular
right you mean that you're trying to
learn the IP addresses that are
typically there for you just like the
structure of the entire picture well you
know you learn what you can came very
fast now it's easier to write it then
when it's like everything right right
right yeah so I mean you learn what you
can't attack here you know I mean this
is this is just a thought experiment
right I do mean the defending items
right the information was the specific
IP addresses there's a lot of
information you can code that after you
let me but then it's gonna be like a
little that space into the design of the
algorithm this space to the home of the
oh yeah
so definite you have to do a proper
Taconic of all the space right yes so
the question is whether you can learn
some patterns here right okay it's a
thought experiment right this is
speculating what they machine learning
algorithm do right yes you know the goal
of this of these bullets here just to
demonstrate that in principle there are
some information that I could be like
right whether the argue is actually
going to do it or not that's a different
story
right yes you know if we know roughly
what the heck is that then you know we
can try to use this information and in
particular you know one natural
approaches to not to avoid collisions of
heavy hitters with other items right or
heavy hitters with each other right
because whenever heavy hitters collide
you know they create lots of error right
so if you can somehow reduce it you know
then you know in principle we could
improve the
all right actually what time do I have
to stop past Oh what happened past all
right okay yes so these are just
addresses that you know they work those
trouble maybe some so so here you just
get the input as described here so there
are no extra levels if you can
accelerate but sure you could
potentially use it right but as it is
you know you just get this information
right the stream which actually carries
information right because you know if
you look at the perfect of the stream
and you see one one one one one one one
one one right then your chances are that
one is the heavy thing yeah that's it I
think for IP addresses we are I mean for
the network data that we look at we also
use the port ID right so we have more
information
all right so so you know it it works as
a thought experiment so let's see what
exactly do we do so here is our so first
of all we have to define some sort of
overall loss function times the overall
error that are we aim to optimize right
if you want to have a trade-off between
the space and time that's our space and
a role so what we use is this loss
function right so this is basically like
a standard at one error except that the
error is weighted by the frequency of
the actor right so you want to make
fewer errors on the own heavy hitters
okay so this is a error function that
often occurs in practical papers not
much in theory but for example this
paper uses like this charlie
in practice people use all sorts of loss
functions right this is one of them I
believe that Vova
in his papers actually use the opposite
right you took this and divided by Fi
all right so this is the average
relative error right yeah so that values
the very start at types of a loss
function can use I will use this one as
follows right so we take a subset of the
data to train the Oracle the Oracle is
trying to detect heavy-hitters okay the
basic I want to have a magic or a cool
subject now when the steam element comes
it predicts where the element is heavy
or not okay
of course the Sorek was gonna make
mistakes but but that's alright as long
as it doesn't make too many mistakes
once we have this Oracle we basically
build an algorithm and it and
essentially depending on the outcome of
the Oracle we have a different way of
storing this item right so the element
is heavy we just put it in a unique
bucket right so there's a heavy hitter
you know I just put on the side so that
doesn't collide with the rest I mean
this cost a little bit more because we
have to stop the count
and the ID or the cached version of ID
and I said the ref recall its cost that
twice as much as a regular bucket but
but that's okay because we we gain on
the right if the elevators predict is
not heavy we feed it to a standard
sketching out good right and here in the
rest of the stock unless what's of it
otherwise the discussion I'll go this
comes me right so we we tried this
Oracle on the prefix of data and then
for every element you know it either
goes here or here and and that's it
right the estimation is very natural
right you know fellow matters here we
get the exact answer even a mother's
here we get some error and you can see
that the error is controlled right
because you know the error is never
greater than the error of this I'll go
here all right so as long as we have at
least some number of buckets here you
know our total error all right so for
the ethical aspects we do in a way for
the time being I mean that is yeah there
is no assumption so far well count happy
yes yes basically demeaning yes and the
the Oracle is supposed to predict
whether
so what does that mean when you say
trade and Oracle as opposed to just
remind heavy-hitting out okay
can I defer your question to two slides
from now actually that's a very good
question yeah I will get back to it all
right so so this is I got it so we ran
it we tested it on two data set one of
them is a network traffic from al-qaida
and it's a standard a network traffic
data set it's a basically you know it's
towards the traffic of the link it has
many files each file has a one hour of
traffic basically we use that the first
few minutes to train then a few more
minutes to validate and then we test it
on the rest in particuiar on a ping
minute number 20 and 50 just to see how
it behaves this is the histogram right
in the log plot the frequency you can
see that it kind of its kind of
ziff-young I mean not quite right will
be ziff-young do be straight line you
know this thing has a bow you know like
here so it's it's not as if you but it's
a zippy Aneesh I mean saliva because
later when I talk about your ticker
results will model you know the
distribution as if you right so it's not
it's not quite accurate but it's not
that far either and the second dataset
we look at this area where a query log
data set and obviously how many people
have played with it yeah I know because
we go from your paper
I only log data set yeah if you if you
ever have I know 20 minutes you know I
encourage you to look at that it's a
basic ideas are search queries collected
by I well like 10 years ago and
published okay technically they were
anonymize because user IDs were removed
but if you look at the queries
it's actually you know like some pretty
crazy queries of course people put them
out of their names right so some of them
are the anonymized i without the users
are I would say certifiably psychotic
you know that's a very interesting read
right anyway you know we took this data
set cos 90 days you know look the first
few days for training then few days for
validations and then just for testing
either
this one is more religiously following
the so training you can start using it
like five days later oh you really have
to throw it and they make two passes and
let me take out the story the first the
first few days yeah you have to store it
and make a few passes and actually takes
time right so basically the way we
envision using it is that you know if
you you know if you want to monitor
something for some number of time right
you take it for three days you train
your otaku
right put actually takes a while right
and then you use the Sirocco you know
for the you don't have to wait for five
days until to your Oracle is things and
then honey yeah yeah so so I mean so it
sounded between because of the way we
tried this you know the Oracle
I mean it is a streaming algorithm
plethoric now it makes a few passes
yes we tried a bunch of way of
implementing the Orrico decision tree is
actually went very well but they weren't
very compact right so they had a very
good prediction but they also took lots
of space which you know you might want
to save space right was an issue so in
the end we will advance and I will not
get into details of of the architecture
but this data set was easier
so the numerator was smaller this was
more difficult so we used a more complex
and this is the results that we got all
right so there are four graphs here so
let's see what is happening
these are graphs for the Internet
traffic data these are graphs for the
AOL they can and for each of these data
sets we have one plot for can sketch and
one plot for count mean right so come
sketch me on each plot I'm showing the
trade-off between the error right as
defined area and space alright so the
lower the better I mean the lower error
and there are four plots right the blue
in our cases is this classical group
right so here is the classic count
sketch either the trade-off between the
average error and space red the solid
red in all plots is a land version of
the count sketch right with everything
that you train the Oracle right and the
spaces are also included in the in the
total amortized over all days you know
we include the space need to store the
recurrent neural network in the same
plot here so you know you can see that
our the lab version outperforms the
classic version now it's not surprising
because you notice not extra information
the amount by which that are our
performs the classic algorithm is right
so you know it's a largest in count
sketch the gap is smaller for count mean
for Internet traffic and then you know
for search query' you know for arrow
data you know the gap is small but you
know definitely there is a there is a
gap okay now what are the other two
curves this curve here is essentially
augmented come stretch account mean but
that's augmented with the original
training dataset right so if you look at
the original training dataset right you
know you can see in the training data
says what is a heavy hitter what is not
right just all the heavy hitters and
then it gives you some form of oligarchy
all right later when you see an element
you can just say okay was it heavy
hitter then or not if it was a heavy
term dad then you classify heavy hitter
and otherwise of course we have to store
those heavy hitters right but it's an
Oracle and so this tiger it also
improves over so this is essentially
augmented algorithmic not augmented with
the learning on a compressor
right I think it's like a statistical
right or just a storage storage or a
code you can see that it does improve it
doesn't improve as much as the land
version on the Internet traffic data for
a well data actually both behave very
similar and well except for the like
very high space regime right where you
know that the gap starts to grow right
but earlier they basically behave very
similarly as far as we can tell this is
because in interact traffic you know as
you go from one minute to another the
exact IDs change right but overall
patterns you know still remain constant
now for example the traffic can go from
one IP to another IP address but from
the same domain right so this is
something that a table lookup doesn't
capture right because the API changes
but alaric algorithm can discover it
right as you just forget about the
lowest different bits of the IP address
I just focus on the domain it's right so
we think that this is why you get this
gap here but the gap here is
the last curve here the green one
now this is this is actually not an
algorithmic an idea right so this shows
what would happen if we had the
perfectly the Oracle right so our
calendar Oracle is not perfect right but
if we had that heavy perfectly in the
Oracle that this is the thread of the
guidance you know you can see that
there's quite a lot of improvement of
course one has to be tricky because
almost like a chicken a neck right you
know in order to know heavy hitters we
kind of have to know the frequencies but
this is something if we want to predict
in the first place right but it's not
quite that you can an egg because in
this case egg is actually simpler right
on the chicken right because the egg I
mean the you know the Oracle just wants
to you know it's a facet gives you
binary answer right it's um a heavy
hitter of not it doesn't have to
estimate the frequency you know in
principle you know it might be possible
that by using Patel I think I'll go that
you can push things in the space or so
they are amused by the space used by the
yeah yeah and it's amortized over the
whole test so basically what we do is
you know we take this noodle network
lamb it last for all of the minutes
right and then use the same network for
all of the minutes right so each time
you run them something on a different
minute you have to use a different count
sketch and other things but the function
self remains the same um still you try
using just like a swimmy Argan like fish
degrees which is already data adaptive
yeah yeah so so we didn't compare it to
me he agrees because you know we wanted
to compare Apple to Apple right so we
focus on hashing because it also suppose
delicious and has some other nice
properties right
but yes the Misha Misha Greece
you know I mean it's now that missional
agrees behaves better than coming for
example right if you just run it on
right but you ran it only on you know it
works only on these sessions
illustrations that's correct but you
know we want to compare apples to apples
right so we don't tailor this data sets
you know they all go to the data sets
right it's just the data says that we
know the time yeah yeah but that's
certainly you know if you you know if
you don't use hashing algorithm in
Greece you can detect the phone but that
said you know impress the poor you could
ask out you can use the same approaches
to Michigan automatic that I'll do it
with information you know we have to be
careful to compare other things in the
same class right all right so I think
that I have about five minutes left
right so let me just speed up let me
just mention briefly I will to thicken
results so basically we try to make
sense of our disciplines so we did some
analysis but our focus just on the count
mean algorithm and we assume that the
distribution is ziff-young right meaning
that the frequency is proportional of
the item is proportional to one over
night okay so in this case I mean this
is like a fully described situation so
you know the algorithms will define so
you can compute the expected error these
are the results that we got right so for
the count mean using a K hash tables we
did not manage to quite get exactly
what's the asymptotic order of the error
but how we got the upper and lower
bounds right and they differ by this
factor here which you know for K large
enough it's essentially log n log of n
over B
that's important all right so here you
have a look at here you have blog of n
over B here you could also look at
alright so for this original algorithm
log n now if you use our count mean I
mean you know the quality depends on the
leavening right so if you had a perfect
Oracle now then you get this I mean this
perfect Oracle can be relaxed to have
some smoke there is a traitor
the basic difference is that between
this two is that here you can blow again
well here you have a log n log a square
right of an over B so in the high
accuracy regime where B is comparable to
n right number of items you know this is
a constant where the Tsar Logan sticks
that's basically at least in this range
of parameters you actually get you know
improvement at least for the zipfian
furthermore we prove that this bound
here is actually tied in the sense that
even if you designed your hashing scheme
knowing the full information about the
input right even then you have to pay
this much all right so so this is as
long as I use a count mean estimator
right so this goes way beyond our
algorithm right it's a just allows the
you know algorithm select the hash
functions in arbitrary way arbitrary way
the you know tailored to the stream
right so it's not a purely what the
heavy hitters are you know put them
separate back heads and and whatnot
right so even even then if you use a
hashing based algorithm which uses a
count mean estimator even then the argot
has to pay right so at least in the US
about excess our algorithm this right at
the way we
actually skip this part now the way
prove it is uh you know we prove a
structural lemma which basically shows
that you know without loss of generality
any item which is a pretty heavy cannot
collide missed on the rightness right
basically means that you know
essentially you know what our algorithm
to do which is post heavy-hitter
separately you know is asymptotically
optimal and based on that were able to
show that you know if your input is
ziff-young right and if you follow the
Sahaj Inc approach then no matter how
you assign those elements into the
buckets you know you have to pay
and for the sake of time I'm gonna skip
the intuition about the analysis that
there's a the damage of caffeine with a
cake as fractions is a bit messy but for
a simple cash fractions there is a you
know like a rather clear intuition why
in one case you get log N and in the
other case you get log n over B it just
follows from the fact that in the you
know when you integrate everything in
the land version in the coracle just
ignore the gamekeepers right then that
means that you don't integrate over the
whole range from 1 to n but you
integrate from b to n right and this
basically creates now to conclude so
basically this paper will show that a
learning machine and can help
performance of seema Calgary's it
required the frequency estimation there
are certain drawbacks it takes a while
alright so but once it's right you know
the the accuracy is better at least in
the space of a hashing concurrence we
have some theoretical understandings but
certainly not for but going so far we
couldn't analyze count sketch right cut
mean and we can but the count sketches
are more complicated we have some ideas
right but you know we don't have a
comparable bounds and you know last but
not least this is a very general
approach right so we're interested in
knowing if the some way of to apply the
machine learning or accrues to other
streaming potentially improve the
performance you know what still
hopefully retaining some guarantees nice
you know we don't use wild
[Applause]
so essentially what you're saying up
since that meaningful stationarity of
the distribution serenity and nature of
streaming algorithm is saying I don't
know what's coming
correctly change all the time right
somehow find the setup right right yeah
yeah so I mean so there are two answers
to that one is that your ticker one is
not empirical right so empirically for
this angles to work you you yes you need
to assign what you need to know that the
Oracle that you learn you know has to
make meaningful predictions in the
future right I mean if it doesn't it's
not too bad right you lose a little bit
its but you know you never lost too much
right because you always fall back to
the worst case right but it doesn't care
right so so why would you train it and
use it right yes I mean so that sounds
you can test empirical you know I can
just rather if this your facts right if
the owner yeah that's that's a more it's
a deeper question right because like
what is exactly the right framework that
you need to assume in order to make
meaningful conclusions right so in a way
in this work we kind of I completely
sidesteps the you know the
generalization part you know we can
notice that there's an organization
right you know we only say okay if the
Oracle has a small profit of Pharaoh
then good things happen right but you
know of course you know isn't gonna have
a smoker you're better right I mean
that's that's you can test empirically
but you know to do something about it
you have to have some framework so
that's actually interesting it makes
sense then to run something up streaming
testing or like change point detection
at the same time to say like oh I did
take that actually right diverging from
what I've let you down again yes
actually that's it that's a very that's
a very good idea we were thinking about
it but at the end of the day we just I
give up you know because like already
training all of this was but that's
actually a very very good point I mean
you know ideally you would like to have
some sort of a warning right warning
bell okay you know your are cool you
know just doesn't make any sense
I do have to do something different
right we train we train yeah or if the
simplest guy is just you know forget
about it you know just fall back to the
worst days all right because you know we
you know this how to rhythm you know if
the Oracle doesn't work I mean you still
get some worst case behavior but you
know it's constant factor or less right
and it's me you know at the end of the
day we care about the constant factors
it will be nice to be able to say okay
your Oracle does not make any sense you
know just so for the for the for this
for exponent of one I mean if it's a
alpha which is different than one you
get some dependence on alpha right we
actually didn't go carefully for that
the reason we focus on alpha equal to
one is because you know this actually is
a pretty close to so if it's not if it's
not quite one you you don't get log n
but you get some dependence on alpha
right thank you alpha is 1 over log n
you know you look at some interpolation
yes but what happens if you just use a
counter in this case SSD so that's a
that's a good question I guess you know
we used a very primitive veg you know
well I guess we'd never actually quite I
sense a good question we never tried it
because it already knows that's true but
the food hashtag also has to store all
the heavy he Clips all right so couch
mean gives you something in between
because it doesn't only store heavy
hitters are still everything but on our
hands
it stores it in a compressed form right
so so actually I have no idea what will
happen okay we can try it yeah
that's again
[Applause]